been described as one of the most
important Free Speech cases in U.S
history and I'm not talking about
Trump's third indictment a class action
against the Biden Administration for
allegedly colluding with and coercing
social media platforms to suppress
disfavored speakers viewpoints and
content during the covid pandemic make
no mistake this is a lawsuit of which
the outcome could have implications for
us or wide-ranging and massive indeed
joining me to debate there's two very
interested parties Dr J bhattacharya is
a co-signatory to this lawsuit a very
outspoken voices against lockdowns
during the Kobe pandemic and former
White House coronavirus response
coordinator Dr Deborah Burks who
publicly witnessed one of the most
infamous it could be called moments
during the pandemic let's just remind
ourselves
right and then I see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute one
minute and is there a way we can do
something like that
by injection inside or or almost a
cleaning because you see it gets in the
lungs and it does a tremendous number
along so it'd be interesting to check
that
Dr Deborah I will come to you first on
that I know you probably end up getting
asked this a lot we don't want to dwell
on that past too much but I remember
watching that very clearly listening to
the president at the time Donald Trump
talking about that talking about
injecting bleach watching you on the
sidelines there and wondering what was
going through your mind
well you know he was talking to Dr
Bryant you can see his head and you can
see he's turned away from me and
um we actually had scientists Dr Bryant
do a study so the kids would get back
outside it was April it was spring I was
worried about kids being inside
um Mayors would not let they closed all
the playgrounds and I wanted children
out on the playground so we asked the
scientists to study sunlight compared to
disinfectant for metal plastic and
cardboard to be able to reassure parents
and mayors that children could go
outside because the sun was a great
disinfectant for covet somehow between
when we discussed that at task force and
45 minutes later when we came to the
Press briefing I think Dr Brian had gone
to the oval and engaged the president in
discussing this as a therapeutic it was
never studied as a therapeutic it was
studied in fact that would be dangerous
it was studied for playgrounds and to
get children outside so you're saying
there was a bit of a miscommunication
going on and I do want to say you've got
a book coming out silent Invasion the
untold story of the Trump Administration
covid-19 and preventing the next
pandemic before it's too late of which
our viewers can maybe hear a bit more
about that but Dr J bhattacharya I want
to come to you on this court case we're
hearing about the moment the Biden
Administration well a case against the
bite Administration this idea that the
government allegedly is coercing or
suppressing social media companies to
silence voices like yours I think it's
fair to say because you have said you've
been sort of Shadow banned on Twitter
for example for things you've said about
lockdowns what made you a co-signatory
on this lawsuit
that there's not there's nothing alleged
about it the Biden Administration has a
uh an enormous censorship complex
basically aimed at controlling and
silencing voices on social media that
criticize its policies in fact it uses
the the the muscle it has over the
regulatory you know regulation of social
media to to induce uh Twitter uh
Facebook you name it to uh to just to
slag lockdown opponents uh and and in
fact to suppress criticism of the
misinformation that the Bible
demonstration itself is putting out on
on things like uh you know immunity
after covet recovery on the inefficacy
of the vaccine to stop disease spread uh
on on the efficacy of mass vastly
overstating the evidence on that on the
harms of the school closures uh it was
on item after item what you see is the
by Administration suppressing the speech
of of of of critics using its government
power to censor in a way that is not
consistent with the American First
Amendment uh well it's alleged until
it's proven in a court of law of course
and that's what we'll have to wait and
see uh but thanks for setting out your
stall on that Dr Burke I want to come to
you and get your response to that
because you have said previously with
regard to kind of the post-match
analysis even though some would argue
the pandemic's still going that some of
the backlash backlash against the way it
was handled to some extent is deserved
or warranted do you think the same with
this social media argument
well you know I loved your last segment
because it talked about empowering the
consumer with all the information they
needed in order to make decisions on
what to buy and even today we don't put
transparent information out there about
infectious diseases I mean we're talking
about an app on buying coffee and we
don't have an app where everybody across
the world can see what's circulating in
their area so they can make decisions
about themselves and their families
because there are people that are still
very vulnerable to covet my mother is 94
in a multi-generational household yes
she's been vaccinated but you know
vaccines and someone that Elderly with
that poor of an immune response she may
not mount an immune response and so it's
my job to provide the tools that we have
to protect her but every family is
different and that's why I've always
found I've worked in pandemics around
the globe if you empower the community
with the information that they need they
will make Common Sense decisions that
protect themselves and their families
I've seen this with covid I've seen it
with zika I've seen it with ebola and I
don't know why we can't give people
transparent information that they can
utilize on a day-to-day basis well
certainly plenty of Health officials
yourself included both of you trying to
get the information that you saw was
right in scientific out during the
pandemic also Dr fauci also here in the
United Kingdom Chris Whitty these top
scientists but it could be argued that
the relationship between the public and
the scientists the public health
authorities broke down so dramatically
over the course of the pandemic where
that was due to government Behavior or
what some would call unelected
bureaucrats overstepping the line
depending on what side of the argument
you sit on but in terms of disseminating
that information and the public actually
taking it on board Dr bhattacharya can
you not understand that there is an
element of misinformation when it comes
to things like Twitter or should we
publish call it now X does it not
concern you
I mean I think the the solution to
misinformation of any sort is uh is
trust and what happened during the
pandemic is that the government it's
embraced uh censorship and embraced uh
positions that were contrary to the
science and then closed up the
possibility of debate and criticism from
the outside and as a result vast numbers
of people no longer trust the government
product the information that provides
and so when there is actual
misinformation of foot
um you know there's they're not going to
trust uh you know the uscdc or the US
NIH anymore because the NIH and the CDC
itself embraced in misinformation uh so
if you want to combat misinformation the
answer is not censorship the answer is
is to build trust in public institutions
by behaving in trustworthy ways and that
is not what happened by the way a court
actually did find the findings it's not
no longer alleged the court actually did
find uh that the census is going on body
by Administration is these are facts
that were entered in court not just
distributed by the government their
emails depositions of Tony fauci and
others in the government who
participated in the censorship
industrial complex uh I just want to ask
you what that trustworthy Behavior would
look like if you boil it down because if
you have that volume of information
coming at the public they're trying to
work out who they can trust or not and
this is what the kobe pandemic felt like
for many what does that trustworthy
Behavior look like how can people
discern it
well I think one is humility and
openness to to criticism right so if you
have a a high government official saying
if you criticize me you're not simply
criticizing a man you are criticizing
science itself well that's just
ridiculous no one who can look at that
and say well yeah that person actually
is is able to keep an open mind and see
if he's wrong admit it
um that kind of behavior exemplifies
exactly how the government behaved
throughout the pandemic and as a result
a tremendous number of people and they
got things wrong it wasn't simply that
they were embracing science and they got
it right and they're criticizing people
on the outside who got it wrong they got
things wrong over and over and over
again the app the uh they over emphasize
the efficacy of masking and mass
mandates they ignored immunity after
covert recovery
um they they they they ignore the the
the vast evidence that if you get the
vaccine you can be infected again oh and
and embraced mandates in its place now a
lot of people lost their jobs over this
so you know it's not like it's it's so
clear that the government got it right
uh and then they also block debate I
mean I think if you want to build trust
you have to build institutions that are
willing to engage in debate and and be
open-minded instead of what we had
during the pandemic and it's funny Dr
Burke who mentions that we're speaking
about culturals that start the show and
values based buying because a lot of
this does strike to that argument about
whether people are thinking in an
ideological way or believing science and
whether both can happen at the same time
it's all about freedom of speech it's
all about being able to choose your side
isn't it but when it comes to a pandemic
and a public health emergency do
scientists know best is there a
rationale for them overstepping and
dictating how people should live
well I think we've learned from prior
pandemics that you have to put all the
information out there in a digestible
way and when you cut Corners when you
cut Corners pretending that if you're
infected you are protected from future
infections you're not protected from
covet if you've been naturally infected
or multiply vaccinated you can get
infected and I just I just feel like
we've divided this into an absolute when
this is not an absolute virus we don't
even know to this day whether long coved
what it really is how many people get it
and what are the long-term consequences
of multiple covet infections it is not
flu it's a unique virus it's it is still
being discovered what it does and I I
agree with Dr J about really continuing
to put the information out there in an
honest and transparent way so that
people can make decisions by both
ignoring the fact that covet is still
with us as well as pretending that our
vaccines can reduce herd immunity and
protect against infection leads people
absolutely confused and you see this
even now today in the United States
where they have politicized rural health
and implying that people in rural areas
are dying at a higher rate because of
their vaccine status it is because they
don't have access to any tools because
Primary Care isn't there anymore and
they've been dying at a higher rate from
cancer diabetes hypertension all of
these other diseases for 15 years and
we're acting like it was because of how
they voted versus their access to health
care so I'm hoping that everybody steps
back and looks at what the true issues
are and for the UK please keep your data
up we've decided that coven doesn't
exist and we've taken our data down so I
use your data to understand what's
happening and what we're going to see in
the United States in order to protect my
mother are you going to get a lot more
data price a lot of people covered in
the UK at the moment Dr J before we wrap
up organization I just want to ask you
where information is one thing but
legislation of course is another at
least 30 states with Republican
legislation have passed laws since 2020
limiting Public Health authorities that
was reported in the Washington Post so
basically legislating into the next
pandemic that Health authorities can't
say You must wear a mask or these
schools can't be locked down depends on
a state-by-state basis do you think
that's wise
yes I do I think that the public health
authorities abuse the TR their trust the
public had in them during the pandemic
violated basic civil liberties including
freedom of speech freedom of Association
freedom to worship uh and huge huge
violations of basic rights uh people
people like need to live they need to
you know go see their their elderly
parents they need to they and
authoritarian orders that violate that
that uh should not be given in the hands
of Public Health who can't be who have
shown themselves to be untrustworthy if
Public Health wants to control Behavior
they should do it in honest Ways by
giving good solid information being open
to correction from the outside and then
if they're giving honest advice people
will listen to it it's trust that is the
key not mandates and authority of the
sort of Public Health irrigated as well
itself during the pandemic